foreign
traffic
coming up to the light
it's gonna turn
what sound
yeah there's no Justin I'm coming
archery you know I should have picked up
I'm not sure the unit in front of me yet
here
I go the wrong way on the interstate
from a shop down off ramp
all right
that's great
probably like red shirt beard
at West Bell North Road Westfield
any fail
negative
wrong way wrong way
100 blocks
back in the right lane of travel
foreign
Victoria takes over
[Music]
here
Corey where you at now
r393
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Northbound into the new Butler Plaza
Boulevard
[Music]
we ran my vehicle
all right we're back on Archer Road I am
now the weed vehicle
[Music]
oh signal foreign
coming up to 34th Street
[Music]
60 mile an hour
Northbound 34th Street northbound 34th
Street
[Music]
trying to get up to a pit
continue on
[Music]
tomorrow we're still continuing
northbound
ER
[Music]
it's good to see the house is now
[Applause]
come on standby
are going
to improvements
everybody hold the traffic we're through
the parking lot we're about to come out
of 34th Street
[Music]
the games coming back out on the 34th
Street going back southbound 34th
[Music]
foreign
I need to block all right damn wrong I
ain't blaming the police they just
protecting the police
all right hey this is
[Applause]
coming down the hill got two on foot
all right
coming down the rim great sweatshirt
black pants mask off
guy just jumped out he just jumped down
hey whoever that is right here
yo secure him
give me one black male gray hoodie black
pants running down the parking deck and
another black melon all black clothing
all right
four positions
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we are on kids
at 104.
I go Thursday
the TV on backup
let me around so hard
foreign
what's wrong with you man could have
killed somebody yourself
foreign
thank you
right now
[Music]
unfortunately
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone
remember us
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
why are you running
huh
what do you mean how was you driving
running stop signs you ran three times
all right roll over on your butt
oh
we gotta go
the other side
Robert zebra baker9932 rzb 9932 it's on
a red Camaro
foreign
[Music]
oh
though
speed safety passing Ponderosa Trace
e
not too long
already
[Music]
yep right on 54.
no traffic
right here can you patches I believe I
got a deputy behind me we're coming down
the road speed 70. no traffic
can you advise reaction was able to take
the female from WingStop
second left on McDonough Road
12 months clear to pit
director
thank you
felt the garage speed 80. no traffic
no traffic
won't let me down the road
96 light traffic
okay
just pulled back into the parking lot
all right
okay well we're turning 80 with a rifle
pair of myself
traffic
12 15 55 go to Wingstop see what
information we get
seriously well he's on the wrong side of
the road waiting on the right side of
the roadway in and out of traffic he's
on the road
he's about 52 still light traffic
we have over 100 by 105.
blacking out
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
come on
everybody
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
guys
are wondering
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
over there
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
big one
foreign
[Music]
yet
whatever
[Music]
anymore
here we got it
right now
[Music]
everywhere
television
[Music]
I gotta
come along
[Music]
16.
foreign
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
I'm sorry BMW
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Ohio
fuck around
Walmart
here at Walmart
foreign